everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 13 of
our coverage of the 2016 Canada's
tournament winner of this tournament
does go on taste magnus carlsen in
november for the world championships
we're gonna go over two things today one
is we have a match between a toe blob
and nakamura after that we're going to
go over round 14 preview and talk about
who can actually win this tournament
both of the competitors today although
an exciting match none of them can win
this tournament so without further ado
we'll go ahead and get into it toe blob
playing the white pieces probably having
one of the worst tournaments he's had in
a long time nakamura playing the black
pieces got out to a rough start in the
tournament towards the back half of the
tournament he has played extremely well
he was my pre tournament favorite to win
unfortunately for him he will not be
winning but we're going to get started
pawn to d4 Knight f6 pawn ac4 pani 69 f
3 and then pawn d5 getting into the
Queens gambit decline lines toe blob
continues Knight c3 Bishop e7 and Bishop
f4 I always like to get the dark square
Bishop involved before the pawn to e3
just solidifying that pawn chain
blocking the dark square Bishop out
guess on the kingside pawn to a three
and then pawn down here to see five we
do see an exchange on board bringing the
bishop down here to see five I like this
exchange for black black still has two
central pawns and he does have a very
aggressive dark square Bishop right here
pawn to e3 just solidifying at this pawn
chain right here Knight to c6 just
developing a little bit pawn takes on d5
pawn recaptures and then pawn up here to
abbey for now almost always you're going
to see one or two moves Bishop back here
to be six and then Bishop to d6 these
are the most common we've kind of seen
these for a long time in this particular
line of the Queen's game of decline but
Nakamura kind of brought a novelty to
this opening it caught totally by
surprise if you kind of watched this
match even the commentators were
impressed by this movement its pawn to
d4 and it puts a little bit of strain on
white as far as how he continues doesn't
just want to take right here on c5 and
just allow this pawn here on c3 to just
do a lot of work so
that's going to be bad instead he
decides to go and take with this pawn I
think it's probably best if topalov
plays Knight to a 4 here but still
somewhat awkward but decides to go ahead
and take with his pawn right here and
then the bishop recaptures now this
Bishop is pretty safe it has night with
protection has the Queen protection
right here it's just completely all up
in whites business right here so decides
to go and take it with this night and
then night recaptures and then the
bishop back here to e3 probably a little
bit better than taking with the Knights
and then the Queen comin down here and
capturing here on d4 after the Queen
takes Knight takes here on d4 castle on
the queenside this is probably better
for whites once the Queen's come off the
board you don't have to worry as much
about your King being exposed and this
is pretty aggressive from whites and so
nakamura looked at this and said ok I
don't necessarily want to go down that
line so instead of taking them with the
Queen right here decides to go ahead and
take with the night and just have that
protection back here with his queen now
this bishops going to attack the night I
decided to go and bring it back here to
f5 and then we see the Queen's come off
the board we now see toefl i play a
bishop be 2nite takes on a 3 after the
pond recaptures white now has an
isolated pawn on the e-file so nakamura
his plan ate his playing beat implants e
are all to attack this pond right here
on a 3 in taupe love pretty much he's
just trying to stay aggressive he
doesn't want to spend all his material
just protecting the pond so that's kind
of his game plan as well Knight to g4
immediately starts to attack the pawn
pawn to e4 really the only way to kind
of defend that Bishop e6 just getting
involved into the game castle on the
kingside night to e3 attacking the rook
rook to see one and then work down here
to d2 so nakamura doing a good job of
being aggressive any time you can get
your books to your opponent's
second-ranked so for white that would be
the seventh ring for black that would be
the second-ranked it's very very
powerful usually you can get behind a
lot of ponds or attack ponds that are
already there and so it's definitely
good especially if you can get two rooks
involvement of the game they can kind of
support each other in the game so right
now the rook is threatening this bishop
the bishop moves to eat
our to f3 this is supporting the square
here on a g2 which is being attacked by
both the night and the rook it's very
very powerful and it's defending at the
square here on e4 room over here d 8 and
then pawn to e5 this is kind of tricky
does have a discovered attack the bishop
is now attacking the square on b7 but no
longer canvas lights for a bishop defend
this pawn on e5 so nakamura he's going
to continue to just chip away and try to
attack this square here on e5 but first
place pawn to be 6 wants to make sure is
[ __ ] or this bishop here on f3 is not
attacking that and then night to e4 rook
to be to a rook to e1 attacking the
night the night comes back to see for
attacking this pawn on e5 and then I
it's almost forced to move so that the
rook can kind of protect this after a
pond age 6 we do see an exchange on
board so we do have a double isolated
pawns right here so so blob is going to
be looking to attack this pawn on a six
Nakamura on the other side is going to
be looking to get his other work
involved maybe to the second rank and
start to attack this square here on e5
rook to see one attacking the Knights
now the rooks going to come down here to
d4 wants to maintain control of the
night here on c4 and so let's go and
play pretty aggressive rook here to adi
for bikes pretty good about keeping most
of his material especially as powerful
pieces on these dark squares so these
light squared bishops can't really do
much harm pawn to h3 pawn to b5 just
solidifying this outpost here so the
root can kind of maneuver can come over
here to f4 if it wants to put a lot of
pressure on board without having to
really control the Knights with the rook
it's kind of free to roam it can also
come down to the second rank if it wants
to hook up here to see three and then
rook down here to d2 so now this Bishop
on f3 is forced to stay on this light
square diagonal because it has to
protect this square here on g2 from
these double Brooks pawn to a4 pawn to
a6 and then Bishop back here to be six
or b7 night to be six and then pawn
takes on at b5 this is one of those
where the bishop as we talked about
can't really come to a six because then
just night to g2 this
is pretty tough to deal with King to h1
all of a sudden White's going to be down
in material because of this he has a
passed pawn that's going to be very
difficult for white to deal with all in
all this is going to be a tough road for
toe claw so he decides to go ahead and
take with his pawn now after the pond
recaptures now Bishop back here to e4
just solidifying the central of the
board I'll bet then Knight to c4
threatening this pawn right here on e5
looking to go up material on board now
rook to a g3 rook over here to e2 and
it's kind of interesting i think till
vallabh should in this position just
look to exchange on board rook takes on
e 2 we see in exchange starts to get
some of that material on board Bishop
back here to see 6 we do see the rook
take but then look here to f3 although
black is up mid material I do think
white can maybe hold on for a tie in
this position after the brook came here
to e2 unfortunately Topalov made a
pretty big blunder and played rook here
to a once just a little bit late on
board he could have played it a few
moves earlier to start to get involved
attack on the queenside but
unfortunately it's just too late the
Knights going to take care on e5 and
after the rook 288 King to f7 egan chase
as much as he wants to unfortunately
it's just not going to be enough bishop
here to h7 pawn down here to g5 bishop
g8 King down here f6 there's just not
enough material on board this night on
e5 just does so well protecting the
square here on f3 where the rook would
really like to come to recover here f8
came back here to g7 rook e8 night at g6
after the bishop takes then Knight to f4
and this is kind of the dagger right
here one of these pieces is going to
fall if the bishop does fall then the
the rook is going to fall this is just
going to be all sorts of badness you
know the rook can even get involved if
he wants to so many bad things that can
happen here this position toe bob was
forced to resign so congratulations to
knock more for a hard-fought victory
trying to go out of this tournament
above winning percentage which it didn't
look like he was going to I really on so
congratulations Tim toe claw having just
a terrible tournament five losses so far
through 13 rounds is definitely one of
the worst he's had in a long time but
more importantly we have an epic last
round coming up so we had two matches
today both go past a hundred moves so we
had fabiano caruana pain peters fiedler
and it looked like fabiano had a winning
position now it was a rook and Bishop
burst rook in game if you kind of looked
at the the computer analysis and the
Grandmaster is kind of going over their
coverage it went from fabiano was had a
potential mating to all of a sudden it's
even but it didn't really look like
fabiano made any mistakes it was an
extremely long and tough in game all in
all I don't think fabiano could have won
but it was an epic match fabiano tied
his game Saratoga County yakin and levon
aronian they went past a hundred moves
as well they ended up tying which means
that tomorrow we have Sergei karyakin
and we have fabiano caruana they're both
tied in first place and lo and behold as
fate has it they actually played
together in around 14 now this is not
because they were in first place it just
so happens that they already had the
schedule they were destined to play in
the final round now vision 9 is a half a
point behind both of them but he cannot
win the tournament so what kind of run
through and what we'll talk about this
more tomorrow if either player wins
tomorrow sir da or fabiano if one of
them wins they will go on to win the
tournament that that's probably obvious
if they tie then by default Saratoga
County hackin will win because he has
more wins in the tournament but there's
a caveat if a non wins his match
tomorrow no this get somewhat confusing
but if a non wins his game tomorrow a
piece he plays Peter Svidler he is
playing the black pieces so it's going
to be tough but if a non wins with the
black pieces and sur de gate and fabiano
tie than fabiano wax
get the tiebreaker it will be a
three-way tie up top with a non fabiano
and Sarah gay in an ngon or excuse me
fabiano has the best tiebreaker because
he kind of beat up on a non so all in
all if you're hoping for an American to
win this to play magnus carlsen you're
one just hoping for fabiana to win if he
doesn't win then you really are hoping
that a non wins tomorrow because then
it's high would give fabiano the victory
all in all though there's only two
players that can win this tournament so
sir gaer fabiano after tomorrow will be
the champion so Sergei is going to be
playing the white pieces fabiano is
going to be playing the black pieces
it's going to be epic that is going to
be the match that we will cover win lose
or draw so be looking forward to that if
you can I think it'd be really cool not
to have any spoilers just watch the
match tomorrow the replay and we will
try to disguise the winner as much as
possible but that's going to be epic
make sure you check that out tomorrow
but everyone say thanks so much for
watching after 13 rounds it's been a
pretty epic tournament can't wait for
round 14 see you guys tomorrow